hey uh one more thing yeah like so you
know how you shave your own head right
yeah all right so have you ever like
just like
shaved the whole thing
oh my god it does
oh
they asked me to ask you what yeah
they were like ask him before you come
out there like ask him if he saves his
whole body help me
ask him does he go completely or is it a
little airstrip what does he do yeah
yes
i don't want you to be uncomfortable i
like to slouch well i'll have a slouch
yeah okay just what's going on here
what's going on here that's my
what's why
why are you facing that towards me
i'm facing it towards you because you
subconsciously asked me to think yeah
yeah yeah you're sure
you're the king
you're all right all right welcome all
right
and who's in charge oh my god
all right let's start again all right
let's start again
hi ricky
how are you dear i'm not too bad
actually hey
what's your fragrance called then
instinct oh can i have a sniff yes
it's
nice
you're okay with that aren't you you're
okay with being smelling nice yeah yeah
i love beans do you like men coming up
and sniffing you love it
love it you're in the right game then
really aren't you
you're so badass in that movie that's
fantastic thank you man thank you no
really i'm kind of a little bit scared
of you what's that smell i went
i went to the bathroom a little bit
no
yes in my pants
how are you good man yeah yeah hey knock
it off oh just a little bit all right do
it again okay now put my hair a little
bit little nah
i am delighted that you're here i i have
to confess i'm very jealous of you why
well because i think of you as being one
of those guys that can just grow a beard
like any time you want yeah i'm very
jealous of that skill this is two days
old it's unbelievable to me i've seen
you sometimes that you're so so beardy
and then it's not there at all and then
it's back again yeah i get that from my
grandmother
now what about you do you get facial
hair not at all
no i can grow hair anywhere except my
face
like if i need hair around my genitals
yeah there it is yeah
are you are you are you i read your
tweets
as if you tweeted that
grimoire hero
yeah lol yeah hashtag yeah harry
you're on the tweety aren't you not
really no i tried to do it and then i
get angry at it don't do it for a while
and then do it oh no wait that's
masturbation but it's the same
are you
hairy further down like are you here
like do you have a hairy back
are you practicing ice breakers on me
yeah
that's kind of my job you you look
sensational have you been working on
your i mean your upper chest just right
there that's it i mean it's really it's
buff thank you it's like it's oh
yeah that's the sound i make when i do
it really yeah dude you see me in the
flies i go
really
do you do the upside down ones what are
they called i do the upside they're
called the upside the upside down i go
to the gym and i just i make a lot of
noise because i want people to see me
lifting weights
do you ever see those guys that try to
lift like a thousand pounds yes why do
they do that i don't know you're going
to hurt yourself doing this things are
popping out yeah
[Music]
that's what i'm there for that's the
only reason i go to the gym things
popping out
there with my binoculars
even although we're indoors and it's
quite a small room i still carry
binoculars so people know i'm a pervert
it's fun yeah especially when they're
wearing spandex you just see you go
how many stone are you
uh i'm 200 pounds what's that in stone
no idea
how many stone are you i don't know
well why are you in pounds i don't know
you don't weigh yourself you're so wise
it keeps me out of this
this guy here i don't know they don't no
don't that's it if you keep sitting with
your legs like that i'm going to get you
some tickets to a broadway show
yeah
thank you
i can't move it because i'll crush the
sloth
right you're a is that is that a sex
thing crushing this
all right you're you're a what is he a
gay robot skeleton yeah right i can see
he's caesar skeletons he's a robot his
name's jeff but what what have you done
this guy
what's going on come over here and i'll
show you
hey i love you wow that's nice
i
i'm very excited to be here
i've been wanting to come visit you for
a long time
yes i wanted to hear a lot for a long
time one of the things i've been wanting
to ask you is yes if you're gonna tear
the card up at the beginning of the
segment yes why even have the card ah
you asked the question that i don't
really know the answer to it i think
what happens is kind of an ocd thing oh
okay i like to i like to have something
to do with my hands otherwise i might
get grabby with the guests
how do you want to finish up you want to
do an awkward pause together you want to
do a fake argument you want to twerk
with the horse anything you want now
[Applause]
hey hey it's his choice now
come on you're david beckham you don't
have to ask your mum for a tattoo now
yeah well she's still every time i have
a tattoo she's like oh my god not
another one really i'm going to get some
more from it but have you ever anything
down that low yeah
that's as low as yeah see that's as low
as you want to go don't go further than
that don't go this far down it's bad
i saw the great spirit
[Music]
you know that it's gonna hurt when the
rest of the guys in the tattoo parlor
are really low yeah it's really low
that's what i'm saying you do smell nice
david
[Music]
the good news is you'll have to keep
making movies in order to pay for this
bar so it's perpetual work for babies
and restaurants right there you go yeah
that's a lot terrible they're expensive
babies as well like you think you've
paid you haven't even started paying yet
i've only i'm not there yet because
everybody's giving me you know everybody
gives you like literally like cool
little cute little outfits and stuff
yeah yeah are you are you wearing any of
those yeah
i have one on now but i didn't wear it
for luck yeah no it's good it looks nice
on you and you can get into it and
that's what's important
that tie is pointing that's what ties do
that's what they're for is it really
yeah that's what i thought like
necklaces do that to cleavage yeah yeah
the necklaces are like here's my boobies
and ties are like guess what this is
yeah but
but according to his memories boobies
are meant to be your arse cheeks that's
what you're saying is going right my ass
cheeks right but why why why would you
want the one with ass cheeks there
that's odd well no it's to represent the
artist why that we know where the ass is
it's a completely different direction
stop doing that with your finger
i'm a doctor oh well all right then oh
he's falling for that one again
no he went to a high school called
punahou right and uh i went to mckinley
he what was
it's a real place
so listen do you want to do an awkward
pause or a mouth organ to get us out of
here uh usually you know i like to it's
a mouth organ well a mouth organ is well
it could be one of two things it can
it's you know it could be a harmonica
right or it could be something involving
a schoondle
do we have a schoondle available to us
i think there's some prospects in the
studio audience but i'm not sure
you mimicked breasts there why
you went like that
oh larger breasts it's
uh smaller
oh one larger than the other ah
you sure you don't want some fruit okay
i mean you don't have to yeah i could i
got no no it was rooted me to turn that
down actually so yeah
oh well for granted i'll take a pump a
pomegranate well look wait before you
look at there's a lot of other things
there to get up look at that you
probably like that you rate a british
bike
there's yeah pomegranate they've got one
of them there's one of them
oh look at this is a little bit like
your name kiwano
what's a kiwano it's a very enigmatic
fruit man
people don't really know much about it
i mean
it's very popular and the girls enjoy it
but nobody
knows how's it going good man you're
styling look at you with the three-piece
thing going on trying to keep up buddy
no no come on man i'm a 50 year old guy
you touch me i'm full apart look at you
you're in shape
you got your little vest thing going on
that's it yeah yeah no it's good yeah
doing the thing and you you're a badass
in this movie that's great i'm pretty
excited about it yeah yeah yeah it's
cool that's kind of a crazy scene i've
never had to do that yeah no have you
ever done any rabbit pornography
yet yeah
that's the way forward for you now
yeah okay okay thanks very much doctor
sorry
[Applause]
do you mind if i masturbate